we lost Penny Marshall recently and I
know that you did brilliant work
together and you guys were close and I
was just curious if if it must be I'm
sure this was a difficult time for you
but just let it be gotta be a lot of
great memories oh did nothing but I mean
we're our all time subjects and you have
to just kind of like bowed in front of
Providence but a penny penny penny shot
way too much on movies like it we we
called it uh we're making movies by
attrition eventually something happens
you have to shop stop building that day
right the Sun Goes Down you run out of
film the crew rebels like a nut there
would be times what I'm saying penny can
you please make up your mind about how
many angles you want from this scene
because we've done 312 takes and he said
well I don't know what I want okay you
can anybody could do an imitation of
their dear penny by just clenching in
their bare teeth and talking mm-hmm
I don't know what I want I'm gonna be in
an editing room in 8 months that I'm
gonna say how come I need a short there
and I don't have it you know why cause
it isn't sort of short like that
so shut up and give me a shot just that
I love that lady and we all miss